Các bạn có chức cấp cao của man ai cập bà kết sang và thủy kì đang tiến hành cơ cố tế xúc kiến
bây giờ chức i rang nhằm kinh kích tay ra nối lại đối thoại vì chính quyền tổng thủy đường
nân trăm. Các nước chung xanh vi vào yvr ăn có thể tham gia đam phán,
để đạt được buồn thọt thọt mọi người nhất là lạy yvr ăn cho bởi cạnh xung đầu giống
Mỹ Sorrell bà yvr ăn đang lau thang. Tuy nhiên, yvr ăn đến ai vẫn suy chỉ là trường
cứng giống. Tổng thủy rang là số và chia skaya mới đây cho biết, bất kì thật nào đã
giống với Mỹ và Sorrell cũng phải công nhận các quyền hợp pháp của nước này bối thung
thịt hải và bà đam an ninh đến nắm chẳng thành động tấn công trong tương lai cho
khi đó, thả báo từ Nguyong Times, các cơ quan tình bảo mi nhận định,
chính quyền đi rang vẫn kiểm soát đến hình và chứ đối mặt với Nguy cơ xúc đầu,
dù đã hứng chủ như được không kích. Hẹn bộ mấy lãnh đại yvr ăn thí tục vận hành
nộ định sau khi chết của đại sáng chủ, ali khả mi này. Bởi con chè ông,
là mosta bà, khả mi này đảm nhận vỷ chi tinh thành tuy cao, và lực lượng về bình kinh mạng hồi giáo,
cũng cứ cơ quan quyền lực vẫn kiểm soát đến nước. Bất chấp dẫn Mỹ đã chia hơn
Mỹ mộ phay bà thì đúng là Mỹ trong tình đầu tiên của chính giây không kích vậy,
và ạ.